i grew up homeless in the wilderness
this is northern california
in the late 70s and through the 80s
where we were
living off grid six years old we're
living out by a stream
there's no roads into where we're at
we've got beams latched up into the
trees
and that's where our bedding is at at
night because there's rattlesnake dens
that's the environment i'm
i'm being taught how to capture live
rattlesnakes by hand
that's the environment i live in like
here's a here's how you
carve a fork stick and this is how you
entice it to strike so that you can
you can capture and pin its neck and
then pick it up and then
hold it and know how to hold and control
this snake while it's wrapping around
your arm with
the only intent in its life at that
point is to kill you
and so you know learning how to manage
your fear because if you don't if you
let fear overtake you you're gonna die
and if you don't respect it and you're
just careless and have no fear
whatsoever you're gonna die
welcome to episode 102 of the michaela
peterson podcast
today i'm happy to introduce chris
duffin for those of you who don't know
him
chris is the world record holder for
squatting and dead lifting
1 000 pounds for reps 1000 pounds
that's incredible not only that he's
also a serial entrepreneur
in health and fitness and the co-founder
of kabuki strength and other multiple
prominent brands we had a chat about his
absolutely unbelievable life story and
entrepreneurial ventures this guy has
been through
so much he lived in the wild
he came from such adversity that
hopefully it'll make you so guilty about
not
improving your own life that you will i
love talking to chris and i think you'll
all enjoy this episode
if you do don't forget to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]
chris duffin welcome to my podcast
yeah thanks for having me on been uh
looking forward to it for this for a
little while
yeah it's it's been a while since i
invited you
i had a had a weird year but i'm glad to
be speaking with you
now well i've been watching it's a a lot
of good stuff always ups and downs but
uh you know the challenges
are they're they're what make us better
right
oh man i hope so and that's kind of what
i want to talk to you about
because you've had a hell of a life so
before we
get into that um can you give a brief
background about
who you are and what you do uh yeah
that's a
it's a little tough to do uh as far as
brief because i play in a lot of
different areas
but uh most people kind of know me as
this uh
guy that's done feats feats of strength
right
uh but uh i also own a number of
companies that i've
co-founded so kabuki strength is the
primary one and we make
the best biomechanically sound barbell
equipment in the world
as well as education and coaching so
we've got
uh probably the leading scientific
advisory board within the uh
within the fitness is definitely
exercise equipment realm uh also
co-founded barefoot
athletics which is a shoe company based
on uh
foot mechanics and build fast formula
which is kind of my supplementation uh
program so so yeah i'm a successful
entrepreneur but before this stuff i
actually did
i did lead turnarounds and things like
that for
about 20 years i ran automotive in
aerospace manufacturing companies doing
turnarounds prepping companies for sale
things of that nature so
um only person that's ever
squatted and deadlifted a thousand
pounds and i did it for reps that'll be
a
a documentary that's coming out next
year so i mentioned all these things
because i like to show
the the end result so when people hear
like where i came from they can
understand um
the you know just how far that is
but uh you know it's it's three things
i've been
highly successful and in leadership in
business
in athletics as well as entrepreneurship
which is usually if i'm one of the other
and so my specialty is kind of
biomechanics as well as
rehab and uh this kind of return to play
getting people out of pain and working
in those areas so i
i do a lot of speaking at like physical
therapy and chiropractic colleges and
other events uh things like that
cool okay we have quite a bit to cover i
think before we get into
the successes i think we should start
with a bit of the hardships you went
through
uh growing up so people can have an idea
of where you came from
yeah i'll uh i'll try to do the elevator
pitch version and hit the high points
but uh i grew up
we're not just talking poor but because
today in this world you see people that
you know have challenged for for you
know income but
they still have their smartphone they
still have their clothes they still have
their gaming centers
i grew up homeless in the wilderness so
this is northern california in the late
70s and through the 80s
where we were living off grid there was
times like
six years old we're living out by a
stream
there's no roads into where we're at
we've got beams lashed up into the trees
and that's where our bedding is at at
night because there's rattlesnake dens
i'm six years old
my brothers four my sisters uh
like one year old and my mom's pregnant
and and that's the environment i'm
i'm being taught how to capture live
rattlesnakes by hand
because that's the environment i live in
like here's a here's how you
carve a forked stick and this is how you
entice it to strike so that you can
you can capture and pin its neck and
then pick it up and then
hold it and know how to hold and control
this snake while it's wrapping around
your arm with
the only intent in its life at that
point is to kill you
and so you know learning how to manage
your fear because if you don't if you
let fear overtake you
you're gonna die and if you don't
respect it
and you're just careless and have no
fear whatsoever you're gonna die
like so i learned these lessons uh
around a lot of things in a different
manner
at a very young age so it was
that bring it wasn't always necessarily
homeless like during the school year we
would be closer to
society we might have something it might
just be missing
a shack missing running water or
electricity or both
so it's like you know during the summer
you're filling up a gallon jug down on
the stream and setting it out on a rock
and letting it heat up through the day
so you can dump it over your head or
you know during the winter it's like in
oregon where we had
you know snow i'd be out in a couple
feet of snow in the back out the back
door after heating up a pot
you know this is in junior high on the
on the wood on the wood stove so i could
try to
try to clean because i'm getting made
fun of at school because i i smell funny
and that's that's just a different
environment and
when you're what people don't realize
yeah
when i talk about it people will kind of
fantasize about it going man that must
have been amazing
but they missed the piece well as far as
they're like the living in the
wilderness and not having you know the
connection with
all the things like we didn't have we
didn't have tv we didn't have radio
we just read books my parents were very
intelligent they just
chose not to be part of society my my
mom was actually going to school to be a
chemical engineer top of her class my
father was a member of mensa
like we our live
the library was was our friend that's
where we read books by candlelight by
flashlight like consumed
mass amount of but what people don't
realize when they kind of romanticize
this life of you know forging for food
and hunting animals and living in tents
and growing up in this off-grid is
the people that are living there for
non-altruistic reasons
are ones that are away from society
because
you know they beat somebody for you know
to death with a tire iron for twenty
dollars
they we had it's
still tough to talk about but i covered
in the scope of the book but i dealt
with
murderers i saved my mother from a
serial killer that tracked her later in
life as well when i got out of prison we
dealt with human trafficking that
directly affected our house as a result
of
uh as a result of police corruption and
so much like
you read my book and it's gonna be like
people be like man
that's crazy go watch the documentary
murder mountain it's on netflix and that
took place
50 miles from where we were at it was
about three hours 50 miles because it's
so
so remote and the roads are windy but
you'll see just how much i'm talking
about
people disappearing murderers serial
killers
corruption all this stuff so it was it
was wild we got taken by the state for a
while
and you know we were in northern
california so just be up front my
parents were growing weed for a living
that's
they're trying to find a way of making a
life outside of society and so we're up
in the
you know the the golden triangle as they
called it which is
kind of what the the murderer mountain
uh documentaries about but in these
remote uh
areas that were highly prized for
growing marijuana
but once they got us back they decided
to stay out of the drug trade so
we moved to oregon the eastern side of
the state where there's a lot of deserts
and
mountains and is more remote and kind of
got into mining
at that point and just fell back right
in the same kind of living just
staying clean of of you know the drug
trade so that they didn't have a chance
of
losing us again and uh things just kind
of
er i ended up kind of helping i had
three younger sisters and a younger
brother and i was
kind of the one that took care of all of
them when they were out tending the
crops who were in later years mining or
i was helping mining and helping with
the kids and then when i
left to go to school which i realized is
the only way out like i'm watching
i'm i'm watching people die around me
i'm watching them go to prison i'm
watching
them succumb to drugs and i'm like
i have to figure a way out of this so
there's no
a lot of people put themselves in this
uh you know burning the bridges
mentality was kind of forced on me
there's just no place to go back to and
so i
i did really well in school as
valedictorian as a state level athlete
and i got a
a a really solid scholarship academic to
go to school for a
dual engineering degree and i'll just
shorten the story here but i ended up
taking custody and raising my three
younger sisters
because things got worse at home once i
left
and like that stabilizing force that i
was in the home
you know i was working and providing
money when i was there you know all
through
junior high high school and
when i left things my my stepfather just
descended into
uh his mental health just deteriorated
to a point my mom
disappeared and i had to i'd just take a
step up so i raised my three younger
sisters
while i pursued my engineering degrees
went on to do my mba i was working
full-time
during that that whole all of that as
well and then
and then all the other stuff happened
after that so
as far as uh the business success and
other stuff but that's that's the early
years so
so yeah i know a little bit about
struggle like i've
had nearly if you talk about like the
nine major
you know things that traumatize people
and affect their their life
i've had eight of them and probably nine
i just have some
uh memory failures in some other areas
and i don't really
feel i need to uh do hypnosis and kind
of explore and bring back some of those
memories so
um yeah yeah i know a little bit about
it
okay well that's a hell of a story
that's sounds like quite a life that you
wouldn't necessarily wish on somebody
this episode is brought to you by
grass-fed beef organs by ancestral
supplements
ancestral supplements makes new zealand
source nose-to-tail organ meats bone
marrow and beef organs
in simple convenient gelatin capsules
traditional peoples native americans and
early ancestral healers believed that
eating the organs from a healthy animal
would strengthen and support the health
of the corresponding organ of the
individual
for instance the traditional way for
instance
the traditional way of treating a person
with a weak heart was to feed the person
the heart of a healthy animal similarly
eating the kidneys of a healthy animal
was believed to support urinary ailments
and overall kidney health
pancreas was fed to people with
digestive problems spleen was
fed to people with immune and blood
deficiencies our early ancestors knew
this
which is why their traditional diets
included the frequent and nourishing
consumption of nose-to-tail organs
visit ancestralsupplements.com to see
what they can do for you
ancestral supplements putting back in
what the modern world
has left out enjoy the rest of the
episode
how did you did you manage to avoid
resentment for some of the things you've
been through
yeah and you'll see it when you read
like
i i still hold you know my parents in
high regard just
i know what they were trying to do and
like my mother still lives
i mean she showed me some amazing things
she showed me
about perseverance no matter what
the struggle always moving forward and
she chose that really hard life but i i
got to experience
just you know the trials and
tribulations that come across from it
and trying to
keep that together the the unity of
family like we did
everything together um and people don't
realize like it was
us against the world and then the
biggest thing that i i've learned is
just this this authenticity this
it's more than authenticity it is
it is doing what you're going to do
being yourself and
creating this own world for yourself
around you
despite what anybody says and living the
way that you want to live
and and and that's that's had a huge
impact on my life i mean that's
that's probably the biggest thing so
those those key attributes
are are really important and i've
rebuilt my relationship with her we have
a
a good relationship um i let her uh
rebuild it with my sisters first because
that was the i was
i wasn't resentful so much as
disappointed and she needed because she
kind of left them
and so she once they had kind of
repaired that relationship i'm like okay
you know it's opening doors for me
because i wanted to be there to support
my sisters first
and so once they they'd rekindle them
and rebuilt that
uh i stepped in and we've had a you know
a very great relationship now the last
like 20 years or so
15 years that it's been
how do you start rebuilding a
relationship with
se with a person who ends up hurting you
by leaving how did you how did you even
start that
yeah so like i said for me it wasn't so
much as
hurting me directly as much as like i
said it was the impact on
that i could have seen that i had on my
on my sisters and that
that's where my priority was but
this i think this might be a
a larger conversation here and
let me diverge a little bit because
there's some i'm going to get back to
your question
but i i i actually see a
pretty significant issue today like in
our media
or with entrepreneurs or athletes and so
on that
they're always talking about having the
right people around you
and cutting out the people that are yeah
naysayers negative the haters and so on
and and i agree like
people are like they're the fuel that
inspires like that is life life is
connections life is where you choose to
invest your efforts and pour yourself
out into and how you're going to affect
the people around you and
and so you need to have that core people
that your
your resources are going to great effort
and affecting
but also that are fueling you that want
to be a
that are challenging you to be a better
you know version
of yourself that ex they're expecting
more of you and you're expecting more of
them
like this is it's so critical to have
this and you'll see this theme in a lot
of things in my life that i've done
around
uh you know entrepreneurship building
business athletics so on
but the big mess here is understanding
that just because somebody
is verbally not agreeing with you
doesn't mean that they're a naysayer or
a hater
and just because there's conflict
doesn't mean that
because that person it's you really
gotta understand those
those root of what they are and why
they're doing the things that they're
doing
because you could have somebody around
you that's raw
all great no conflict easy life
best friend but at the end of the day
they actually they're looking forward to
and enjoy
the times that you fail that they
they don't want you to they don't want
you to succeed
um and you can have somebody else that
is calling you to the table
appears to be a hater but they're doing
it because
they they believe in you and they see
that maybe where you're going and
they're
they're they're challenging you to to
look and reflect at these things in a
manner right and so
this isn't i don't know i'll tie this
back to that conversation but this is a
really important piece that p
i think people really really miss
because
they want to find this environment where
it's conflict-free and easy and
you know it's just like the retiring on
a beach and drinking my ties
but in my workplace is it like that and
and
and it shouldn't be i i see this so much
people want
yes people around them and you're going
to end up
not achieving what you're capable of not
being true to yourself by having people
question you
and like my my businesses we have you
know
some heated staff meetings we have but
it's all because we believe we're
we have the same values we have the same
envision in north star we're all
part of this team to get there and just
because i founded it doesn't mean i
don't get called to the freaking table
uh you know at times and that's that is
really
positive and in so much that
this is one of the core reasons i
separated from my
my first uh my first wife as well
we were good friends it was comfortable
but they didn't want to see me
succeed in these other ventures i wanted
to see some you know failures so that
i'd stay with just the regular job and
be a normal person and not have you know
the challenge uh that it brings and the
chaos that it brings into
life right and so back to your question
that i've been uh
maybe avoiding i don't know i'm thinking
through it while i'm talking which is
hard i'm not a terrible multitasker
it doesn't look like it but
uh i actually am but it's you can focus
on one thing at a time you can do a lot
of good stuff
but but the
uh you know it's understanding that
in her own way my mother wanted the best
for us she wanted
this different environment than most
would have and it ended up bringing a
lot of challenge in strife and trauma
and mixed emotions same with my father i
mean there's
so much like mixed emotions there but at
the same time understanding
i am who i am because of this i wouldn't
trade it
for anything yet at the same time if i
think about my children
being in the environment just the
thought of that
brings just deep sadness to me but i
wouldn't change what i have
for anything because those experiences
top me so much and
my mother you know she wanted to to live
that life and she wanted to have
you know her children understand that
they do the same thing
that they can they can create and build
the world in the manner that they want
they can choose to not be
stuffed into just this pre-packaged
you know life that is that everything
kind of pushes us towards and even more
so now in society that we have now to
just
be a consumer uh you know to have
things filled instead of actually being
out there and creating and forging
things in the way that you want so so
understanding that helps you build a
relationship
and just like so my mother i mean it's
it's just she is so raw and she is
so herself like you sit down with her
and every story ends with her pulling a
gun on someone or some other tragic
thing
which is she's just so so we're on
different but she'll just say things
that are
it's on her mind at the time and it
means nothing in it
you have to just learn to
know that she loves you wants to see the
best for you
but the words you just gotta kind of to
walk past that so once you understand
some of those deeper things that helps
you there when
when you hear something that is just
like wow that would be horrific if
you know somebody if your mother said
something like that to you
give some examples but i don't i don't
think this is the right
form or format for that
okay so this this must have been
something that you've thought about
having kids
how do you create adversity the proper
amount of adversity for your child
so that they grow but not so that it's
like a ridiculous for them right so you
want to keep them safe
but maybe too much safety means they're
gonna have a harder time when things
actually get hard so
have you figured out how to balance that
oh god
i have not figured that out but i can
tell you my approach
so yeah
well let's start with a little bit of
developmental kinesiology first so this
is just straight motor littering
patterns
and that'll help frame my conversation
so
this first piece doesn't directly tie
him but it will from a philosophy
standpoint so
every human being is born with the
patterns of how we move and how we
stabilize
and and that process happens over a
nine-month period of time so
every week and every month the exact
same things will start happening from
moving to a rolling pattern to
reaching and stabilizing with certain
parts of your hand
and then you start advancing to you know
being able to get towards
a standing and then walking position
and everybody's in and it's important
that we
we continually challenge and work it's
just like working out right the more you
do it the better we get the more these
patterns are
able to develop appropriately
what people like to do when their babies
get in that and it's like oh
my baby's walking at eight months or
something and they start holding their
hands and showing people look the
you know my cute little daughter's you
know walking i'm gonna help and here's a
walker and you're walking around
and it actually can create damage
because
you teach to stabilize off of this
distal end it starts elevating a rib
cage
it'll start changing some breathing
patterns and other stuff that happen
and so it's actually bad practice to to
do that consistently and get your baby
walking sooner than it should
in fact you should stick your foot out
and swipe it and knock your baby down
so i'm being a little bit you know
cheeky with this
but they they actually need to
practice and continue to get that and
have the challenge of it and
fail and keep coming back right and
that's how those patterns are taught is
not by just like oh yeah i'm a success
the first time and now i'm walking and i
may need the help and support to get
there
that actually doesn't teach the you know
our body our nervous system
have the practice to be successful so in
in my opinion
one of the best things that you can do
as a parent
is let your child fail
and that is it's not a bad thing think
back on your life and some of your
failures end up being the catalyst
for one significant amount of confidence
and that may not make sense at first but
like once you fail at something
or don't maybe it's not failure but
don't get what you hope you know that's
just failure
and you come back around you study more
you work harder you train longer you
you practice more you and then you come
back around and you and you pull it off
and you do it
like that is that is an
integral part of life because things are
not going to come your way the first
time
and so it's learning the ability to do
that
the ability to not take the initial
failure and
knowing that you have the ability to
come around and get it no matter what
that is huge but the confidence that it
instills
and i didn't start thinking about this
until you know i was kind of challenged
more recently in some
recent years about like my i'm a bit
cocky i'm i'm confident i can believe i
can
i believe i can do these crazy over the
top things if i just
choose to do it it's just a matter of i
haven't chosen to do that yet but i can
do it
it's like where does that come from and
i'm like
it comes from layering
these these overcoming one on top of the
other
so it's just like training you go into
the gym
and you do some curls and your arm gets
a little bit stronger and the next time
around
you know you've got the confidence as
well as the neurological and physical
capabilities
to to do the last workout but do a
little bit more maybe and then you keep
going
because you can't just go into the gym
your first session and squat 500 pounds
right but you can know i could squat 500
pounds
it's just gonna take me a lot of this
stuff that i've learned of discipline
and follow through and stick into a plan
like
and i've demonstrated that in some other
man so i know i can do that right
and but to get there is just layering
the wind on top of the wind on top of
the wind until you get to this point in
life where you're able to
to accomplish crazy over-the-top things
because now you've got
the capacity so and that is
that's the important thing to understand
it's all about building
the capacity to handle these sorts of
things so thinking about it in a workout
space
helps people because you continually
progress your physical capacity right
over time
but that's that's resilience that's
strength strength is resilience your
ability to adapt and overcome
the the stress and the challenges coming
your way well
it is the exact same process
for mind and soul so body you know
building resilience of body mind and
soul are all the same things and i am
i am not over speaking on this i'm not
being ethereal at all
like that if i quit doing the curls
let's say i break my arm and it goes in
a cast what happens nine months later
six months later and then they take the
cast off
atrophied uh arm is atrophied
i'm looking out my window you can't see
but there's some wet trees behind me and
they're blowing in the wind
if those trees were planted in an
environment where there was no wind
they would grow to a certain height and
they would fall over
i'm not making this up it took the
scientists for a while to figure this
out when they were putting trees in
biodomes
because they kept happening didn't
matter what kind but there was no
resilience
telling the tree to build you know gross
strong roots deep into the ground and
root
properly right um the same thing the
outer the bark on the outside will be
different and so on
like it's not i'm not being ethereal
like
this is this isn't just human physiology
this is all living beings
if we do not have challenge
the process basically death this
retiring on the beach
drinking my ties that's the end right
this is why
you could be a war here 20 years ago and
then you didn't nothing
happened you get stopped you could get
soft if you just
sit and do nothing if i don't work out
if i don't work out my mind if i don't
if i don't take on challenge in these
areas you get soft
and next thing you know something's
going to happen and you're going to
freeze up and not be able to handle it
and shut down
right so it's about building and
layering the capacity
and uh and sorry i'm on
i'm off on a tangent i don't know the
original question but
this is i mean this is the whole reason
i wrote my book because all my
businesses are focused on the physical
nature and this is
some of the stuff that i'm trying to
share is
is that all these
challenges and and struggles and strife
in life
they are the things that are going to
allow you to be
better to grow and i don't want to
disregard like if someone's had some
traumatic experiences like
yes that can negatively effectively
if you're that person you hear me i'm
not saying that but i'm saying
it's already happened and it's not the
it's not the definition of who you are
you're defined by your actions and
responses to that and more importantly
if it's already happened why can't you
use what you can from it
in a positive manner to leap
to leap you forward to be that to allow
you to be
stronger to be more resilient for
something else that maybe
in the future that you're you're not
anticipating right and this isn't just
like trauma this is like
this is everything going on around you
every day this is
the hard conversation with your aunt uh
that you
that you have been putting off and don't
want or your your partner
or your boss or your coworker it's the
the project at work
or wherever that your i hope i don't get
like i don't know if i can pull that off
or
that career change that you're
you really want to do and you're you're
excited about but you're anxious what
about like not making
some money or can i pull it off or going
back to school or
starting starting your own company or
any of these sorts of things
they could be small and they could be
big and they're happening to you all the
time
and our inclination when that when our
gut starts like
getting in a knot about those things is
to turn our way
i don't want to have that conversation
now if i don't say it'll go away
it'll go away and
it more than likely it's not going to go
away
and but being the person that practices
going i feel that i feel
myself kind of tensing up that is your
signal right now
that that means that's an opportunity
for me
that is another moment that i can take
advantage of
and practice practice living in that
uncomfortable space
practice being afraid practice
overcoming this and knowing because
there's going to be something more
difficult in the future
than than that you know that
conversation or that that choice
right and so that is your chance to
to take that on and i'm not saying every
one of those is going to be successful
but the practice of doing this certainly
is because that's going to build up your
resilience to take on those things and
guess what
the big things in life that really shake
and change you up aren't things that you
anticipate
some random thursday afternoon wham
you've had some of them happen to you
this year right it's just like you
didn't see that coming
and uh being able to not freeze it up
and lock up and know that
[ __ ] that's hard i got this though i can
figure out a way
i don't know how i'm gonna do this right
now but i know i can overcome it
right okay that was that was fantastic
uh i want to talk a little bit about
your experience
with your body and overcoming things so
i think one of the areas i haven't and
there's reasons for everything
but one of the reason one of the things
that i need to work more on
is my my muscular strength
and the stress resiliency that
potentially comes with
being physically stronger so could you
maybe
talk about your experience about like
what being strong has potentially done
for your
stress tolerance
yeah yeah so it has a much bigger impact
than people think
so i'm going to just start with this
question of
for you what do you think is the number
one
health care cost i don't have the
studies worldwide but health care costs
in america so it could be heart disease
diabetes cancer something else
just a quick shot obesity
low back pain okay
okay yeah low back pain and most
all of low back pain can be dealt with
by having more resilience people don't
realize that
the working out doing it appropriately
shouldn't
cause pain in fact it will make you more
resilient to being able to be in
different positions and be
under load and do these things so that
that one
you know getting out of your car that
one day and twisting or twisting
over reaching down and picking up your
child and all of a sudden it's like damn
that threw my back out yep it wasn't
that same
right yeah well most everybody has at
some point in their life and i'll tell
you about
something i had it happen and i had to
learn to walk again
ah i couldn't move for weeks
not even my head uh what happened i had
to
i had to walk her and i had to learn to
walk to walk again um
well i was challenging myself on the
resilient side too much so this is like
the burning the candle on both ends too
much right
so we've got to understand that anything
even the past conversations i had you
have to temper with
that's pouring your cup out it's like
you know
you're taking on challenge you're
choosing to to dive into these things
you've got to refill it right so
um and some so if you push it too far
and don't have that like obviously i was
saying you know if you rest and recover
constantly or too long the process of
atrophy starts
so we don't want to be but you have to
be there you know intermittently
as we're as we're progressing as we're
taking things off so
a little vacation a little meditation a
little yoga or whatever it is that
that you know reinvigorates you is good
living that for a life
is bad so um anyway
i was pushing my limits trying to do
something over the top
as a long time ago chasing some records
so i didn't mention in my life story yet
i
done a lot of lifting uh so i there's
ranked number one in the world for like
eight years straight
uh uh set all-time
uh records and then later i did uh some
like feats of street
drunks feats of strength things i
mentioned a couple of those
but um somewhere in there i i i pushed
it too far
and that's what happened but i came back
around i had the confidence to come back
around and demonstrate
that i could do something that actually
was the two most demanding
things on being able to stabilize and
maintain spinal position under load
to at a at a level that no one's ever
done before with no
with no back pain so when we talk about
defining yourself a lot of people will
come to this thing going i'm the person
with a bad back or that's going to be
like this forever so yeah let's get back
to developing
let's get back to the conversation about
what is it to develop resilience but
understanding fundamentally it is going
to allow you to withstand
stuff to be able to live a better
quality of life
to have you know all the little things
in life not
cause an injury right to be able to do
something and
improving that physical capacity as a
whole it's also going to have an impact
you need to be chasing these things body
mind and soul
if you're not the uh they're all related
right
so like the strength athlete or you know
meathead guru that's only on this
strength aspect
they're going to have big gaps right
because they're not attacking
you know the other two components and
same thing if you're
focused on self-improvement on those
other two but not addressing this
you're going to i mean just the physical
nature of it is proven over and over
again
to have a huge impact on mental health
so so there it's a matter of being
rounded and being
and pushing that and we we could look at
it back from a
philosophical or yeah well uh great
thinkers of the past but uh
this was a really common uh theme that
you know there's a great uh quote from
socrates although there's questions
about how much of a
an athlete he was hippocrates the you
know founder of modern medicine
has an incredible quote about like
basically like
uh lifting and moving is going to
fundamentally take care of nearly all of
your
physical ailments right so it's a matter
of balancing that with rest god i wish i
had that quote in front of me um
i uh dang it i'm not going to look it up
because that'll interfere
it's important to have that strong mind
and strong back
it's important for not just being able
to
not have back pain right but to
improve your your your immune resistance
your ability to
adapt it all of it actually your body
when this sense is stressed
it is it's all coming from the same
bucket
so this is something like if you're
lifting you have to also understand this
the other stresses in life are going to
put the same kind of drain on you so if
you have major stresses
if your type a personality you know
pushing hard in business world
you can't just walk into the gym and
hammer everything that you got all the
time as well
so it's understanding that but as we're
developing the capacity over time it's
going to have an effect on all those
areas of your life as well
so important important aspect and so
as we're thinking about this thing we
want to think about
how do we build that because a big
a big problem is people jump
into well that's great and then they go
all in oh running's great
i'm gonna go run five miles a day oh i'm
gonna start straining five six days a
week
and and dieting and and and and adding
all this stuff on and what we want to do
is actually there's a reason for this so
i'm not just going to say it
but we want to do it with the what's
called the minimal effective dose
we want to do the minimal amount of work
that's going to allow change
because it's all about layering those
capacities but that means also over time
to achieve more results you have to add
more
so if you throw everything at once up
front then you've got nowhere else to go
we see this like in the dieting world
people want to exercise
take their diet way down uh do you know
maybe even add some drugs in or
you know some stimulants or whatever it
is they put everything in there
and then it's like they make great
progress for like eight weeks and then
it stalls
and where else do you have to go you
can't pull more calories out you can't
exercise more
like you've already you've already put
all that but the other side is also the
injury prevention society and this is
well studied
um is that if so what we have is
basically what is your average like
workload
uh over a period of time so let's say
three to six months time
um the word for that is actually uh
chronic but it
sounds terrible um but uh
that we'll just use average for this
discussion okay so your average workload
and then you have your short period like
in a week and that's called acute
and so over time you want to increase
that that's actually what's going to
provide the gains but not too much
because again you have nowhere else to
reach but also for the reasons and that
if you take the way you do it is you
obviously spike a short term and that's
going to start bringing your average up
but if you bring more than a 10 to 15
percent
increase in volume
over your average that's going to
instigate about 80
of the injuries that we see so in
athletic populations
80 is a result of that not right at the
end at the moment but like five or six
weeks later
you'll see oh man i've got this nagging
elbow the snag being wrist and then that
starts affecting
your long-term adherence and discipline
because now you're off plan you're
reducing
you're coming around uh and you're not
able to
to step that up and then the other so so
so you want to that that's why we can't
just go all in because it's going to we
don't have the capacity
to handle that we have to build that
um and so that's the the important
lesson there is
you've got to stare that up you've got
to stare that up but slowly within that
those tolerance and then understand like
because here's a big problem people have
it's like
oh i was doing a great and then i went
on vacation
and then you come back and you're like
well i missed a week or two
what are you gonna do gonna make up for
lost time and hit it harder
well that's the exact opposite because
you've actually just moved your average
down
and your ability ability to tolerate
that load
coming back again even your normal is
actually reduced
so it's it may not be the message that
people want to hear
but we've got to ease into this stuff
because
but the beautiful thing is it just
builds over time if you
do that that is you're going to build
that capacity over time to handle this
stuff and that's
so these are some fundamental exercise
science stuff this kind of
fits into something called periodization
but
those are really important concepts to
understand because it comes with
everything let's say
minimalist footwear there was a there
was a big
company about 10 a little over 10 years
ago that came out with
finger shoes and there was a documentary
born to run and all the runners great
their mentality is always more
is better right and it's like oh that's
better let's go do it start running 20
20 uh 20 miles a day with those shoes
but they don't have strength in their
foot yet because they haven't built that
capacity their foot's been
all mummified just like if you walked in
every morning if you woke up in the day
and
wrapped your put your weightlifting belt
on and wrapped your elbows and wrapped
your knees
that would actually decrease your
strength right
and it wouldn't make you healthier and
stronger and it would cause
other things to happen in your body
which i'm getting into a whole
minimalist footwear discussion but
they don't their foot's not strong they
haven't been using it and so they go out
and do that
and in fact they actually need to wear
those type of shoes or do that type of
work about ten percent of the time to
start with for the first month
and then increase it and then increase
it because they're actually having to
increase the strength of the foot
that the shoes aren't the answer
having a stronger functional foot is
and their shoes were working against
them in that fashion and this is
this is a really cool story so uh
related to it so i'm on a side topic but
it is very related so um
and this is a documented story by one of
the the original people involved with
with nike uh which has why all running
shoes today
are built with an elevated uh heel and
arch supports
built into them because
they started pushing this as in the 70s
getting
running was not that commonplace within
you know the normal everyday population
there was wrote a book and stuff was
coming in that was starting to a change
that was starting to come about and
they're making their running shoes
and heeled shoes even you know men's
shoes
was was compliment that's and it still
is today and it's actually a result of
far back because
the only reason we have heals is for
stirrups for riding horses
so that's where the whole elevated heel
came from but then it rolled into
fashion right
and then they were starting to promote
running and they're starting to see
injuries well the reason they're seeing
injuries is people didn't have the
capacity within their calf muscles
they've been
sitting in a shortened uh in a shortened
position from all the healed shoes
not the strength from using the foot and
all this sort of stuff and so the
question is what do we do
and uh i think he was a podiatrist
uh and he now says it's the the worst uh
worst decision he uh he definitely worst
decision he made and he
regrets doing it but they suggested
let's just go ahead and put an elevated
heel in the running shoes so that people
don't have those injuries because
they're going to instead of providing
the education
right and now that's what we have around
the world and then now with the elevated
heel
it puts the pressure on the toe we've
got the inward toe and we basically lose
control and stability
of uh the knee and hip complex and so
then you have to passively support it by
building in an arch support because
the system to stabilize that is shut off
you can test this
anyone listening to this get down in a
squat position
barefoot okay and pick your big toe up
and raise and pull it in just like it
was in a shoe and you're healed
and then move your knee around a little
bit you'll see that it just falls inward
and you lack control now grab your big
toe
yeah pull it wider than it normally
would be because by the way it's
deformed from your shoes so pull it out
and press it down and then push that
into the ground and now do the same
test and you'll see a huge difference
so that's interesting isn't it crazy
yeah
um and so because of you know one thing
then you start having to build all these
other band-aids on i mean it's just
straight i mean mega analysis of
all the research uh done on orthotics
which is an entire industry right and
also
a big piece of like shoe design as well
right our athletic
science issue
shows that there is no long-term benefit
whatsoever
there's relief in pain for a six to
eight week period of time just like if
my elbow hurt and i wrapped it
right and the example i was talking
about earlier it's going to provide some
relief but if i wake up every day and do
that all day long
till night long term it's actually going
to cause more problems
and cause problems in other areas of my
body as i start to compensate
so there's no scientific evidence well
actually the scientific evidence is that
it doesn't do anything beneficial
and you know i can i can work with
people and help if you start
strengthening your foot and just using
it you'll see that
back and hip pain uh and knee pain
those sorts of things just start
dissipating but it's not the shoe it's
the the ability to strengthen manage the
the foot complex
well i got on a big tangent but it's
it's strength i like it so
this is and this is the impact of
strength this is what it has
and this is another feeder right into
like the number one healthcare cost of
america back pain so
um so anyway from from a t
while we're on the subject i just want
to cover a couple things so um
the ability to control and manage spinal
mechanics
is the number one global impact on the
whole body
okay and
that is accomplished through the use of
the diaphragm
in relation to the pelvic floor it
sounds like a lot of
you know complexity but it's it's
basically getting your
your rib cage in alignment with the
pelvis and then we use the diaphragm and
it descends downward but basically
imagine inflating your stomach
all 360 degrees around just a little bit
the pressure it depends on the movement
but that will
create the stabilization that actually
creates pressure against all the organs
and the organs around the spine
and then causes a co-contraction you
don't need to know all this stuff
because it'll happen automatically
of all the outer sheath of muscles so
obviously the the abdominals the rectus
the the obliques the thoracic lumbar
musculature as well as the pelvic floor
all come in but the two have to be like
this
now a lot of us walk around with
elevated you know men just kind of show
off their chest
women maybe show off their chest uh
whatever the reason
shoes actually uh kick the pelvis
forward which causes the same so
um and uh so the elevated shoe even in
running or walking causes an over stride
which kicks the pelvis forward as well
it all feeds in as well as stress
and technology so just like being on
technology devices
and high stress situations all cause a
change in breathing patterns
and so the breathing patterns shift into
the chest
instead of what's called diaphragmatic
breathing but you would feel it in your
belly
air still coming in your chest because
this is where your lungs are but
that sensation um
is what the diaphragm but it starts
shifting those those patterns into an
upward motion so your
your shoulders and traps will kind of
elevate if you put your hands up here
your collarbone when you're breathing
it'll move up and down if that's the
case that's not
they shouldn't have an elevation as it's
going it should actually be
outward kind of like a wave from the
bottom up
even into the low ribcage will expand
but not push
forward so we don't want to elevate our
chest anyway that's important to
understand because if the breathing
patterns break down that's one function
of the diaphragm
so the diaphragm covers respiration
stabilization in the sphincter but the
it'll start messing with the
stabilization function and so then now
we start getting a lot of stuff going on
and so if we don't have stability
our body starts compensating uh by
tightening
if if if it senses that there's
instability
or weakness so again this could be the
foot with our packaged up shoe
it'll start tightening the muscles
around the joint to protect it
and so the best way a great way to
explain this is a car analogy
so most modern cars
they have a traction control little
button in there right and a lot of
people think that
when the traction control is on if i'm
going around a corner and it's wet
or icy it's going to take the power from
the wheels that are slipping
and put it to the wheels that are
gripping but it doesn't do
that it wants to do the same thing your
your neurological system and your body
does which is
if it senses that you're in danger
because we lack stability or
uh or strength it wants to save you so
that you don't go sliding off the road
and
burn a fiery death for example in the
car examples so how it
does this it goes ah we don't have
stability
we're going to reduce the we're going to
reduce the uh
the the um sorry
too much talking for me today so
it's going to uh [ __ ] the timing on
the on the engine it's going to reduce
the power output of the vehicle it's
going to reduce the shift patterns
and it's going to detune the system
so that as we do that now the tires
don't slip and we don't burn that fiery
death by
flying off the road well our body does
the same thing
so you think about that even from a
training perspective like
that means like it's not just a
conversation of
of health and you know uh you know and
as far as injury prevention but
actually just being able to realize your
potential so if we've got
our stabilization mechanisms on we can
do just like a performance race car that
doesn't have attraction control
it's like put on a good good pair of
tires that are connected to the ground
our feet put the foot you know you know
put our foot to the uh
to the to the floor on the gas pedal and
you know take it
so that is uh our body does the same
thing so like people that
you know have tight hips from squatting
well they don't have tight hips from
squatting they have tight hips from
squatting
like [ __ ] so if you're not moving well
and you're you are going to have this
stuff happen
and so so it's just an important piece
to understand like how important these
mechanisms are
so if i don't control so the the spine
and the spinal mechanics is number one
largest global impact the foot is number
two
as the secondary largest so so
these have a huge impact for our whole
body and being able to we need to be
able to strengthen and use those
resources and learn how to manage and
control them it's that simple
that was the okay
no no no i i actually i actually have a
few questions so i
have two um i i've done some research
i mean i have like an ankle replacement
which really screwed up one of my legs
so
i know about foot problems but also
since having a kid
i've seen these you know seen these
shoes where it's like this is what a
human foot is supposed to look like and
it looks kind of like a hand
and then you see what a human foot from
wearing shoes looks like and i was like
oh my god i don't want to do that to
scarlet
like my little kid like make her shoot
feet are all screwed up
so but she doesn't like she's a super
girly girl she
only wears pink she doesn't like the
shoes that aren't gonna
destroy her feet so she's been wearing
flip-flops
so how do you feel about flip-flops
versus the ones that
constrict your foot um
so there's a lot of people that will
tell you that flip-flops are bad
they are far superior to putting the
foot
in a skew because the shoe is physically
going to deform it
the only negative is a slight like
having to pick it up so if you can get
something that maybe has
a strap or something or just like
catches on the front of the foot too
in a fact that they don't have to really
hold it on with any toe work
oh okay okay and then also the great
thing about flip-flops is they kick off
really easy
because that's your time like being able
to feel and move the ground uh
you know run around in the backyard on
the grass and have some you know be able
to move the foot
um play i mean that is
and so you don't have to i'm not this
hardcore like oh you've got to live a
barefoot lifestyle like you know
if i go out to dinner my wife may dress
up and put on a pair of heels like
yeah so um but you still need it's just
like
spend some time using them and
strengthening them and then in the
in the shoe they'll they'll work better
but yeah it's a big problem with the
minimalist uh
movement this is gonna sound really bad
uh the way i frame it and hopefully
nobody takes this personally but
like it they're all designed for hippies
and runners
and i'll tell you if i start wearing
those like those finger shoes that i i
mentioned
if i could go home and my wife sees me
in the nose
like her sex drive or interest in me is
like this and
we're i'm like i it's i
i just state in reality uh and i
you know that's uh if you want to have
if you want to enjoy some bedroom time
with your partner
a lot of those are just not good choices
right so
so this is a reality like fashion is
important and
and it's gonna it's a reality maybe it's
not important but it is a reality that
we live in
and and so um that has been
an important piece that i'm trying to
address again you know i live in
portland yeah i've got a lot of hippies
and runners as friends i'm just like
joking
about it not joking about the sex thing
though that's real
but with the toe shoes it's definitely
real it's definitely real yeah
but all the minimalist companies are
focused on the same target market and so
they're not providing
any alternatives for the rest of the
world yeah
right and so that's uh that's all i'm
trying to do with my company barefoot
that's be ar um
like a kid running around in the
mountains uh running from bears barefoot
like
i was you know nice anyway um so uh
but it's to to create something that is
that looks
better that you could wear like i'll
wear mine with a with a suit you know
maybe it wouldn't work for a lot of
people in some suit environments but you
get my friend like it works
great in a lot of environments and we're
coming out with a boot next
and the boot is designed for people that
go hunting
that have a blue collared job where
they've got to wear a work boot because
these people boots are absolutely
horrible for feet
the stiffness and the like the ability
of how they control the foot
and once you start like doing and your
foot starts working right
boots will just make you ache and hurt
nearly immediately
and i get comments like what do i do
when i go to work
because there's no great alternatives so
this fall we're coming out with one it's
actually
being tested by an elite uh green beret
team
uh right now so uh getting it
put thoroughly through its paces but
it's you know it's a
god i hate the word alpha but it's like
you know it's that for that type of care
person uh that is living in this
environment that is
will never put on a on a shoe that is
targeted towards the
the other environment right so yeah
anyway it's
just helping you know
helping a different group that doesn't
have an alternative right now
and i don't have a i don't have any kids
shoes yet so um
and yeah a lot of them are the the girly
girls like my daughter
same thing she you know she's only three
years old but
she's gotta have you know uh but the
alternative is just making sure that
they have time
to play without shoes so it doesn't have
to be all the time
and that is that's the issue because
some you know it's just like over time
people think it's like oh you're just
you're just not buying the shoes that
fit
but over your life you'll see that your
your foot will change so you spend i
spent five
i spent about six years barefoot and the
shape of my foot and its functionality
changed dramatically
and my thousand pound squat for reps my
thousand pound deadlift for reps
those were done shoeless even though i
have the company because
like i'm not trying to sell you a shoe
like this is like this is something i
believe in
if you can go train that way just go
train that way right
uh but i did that because it's a
performance enhancer
like i'm able to perform better i have a
greater connection and proprioception to
the ground right
and so all the stuff that i design is
kind of built around these concepts like
kabuki strength
um our products were used by
29 of the 30 major league baseball teams
we're used by 90
of all professional sports in north
america
we're used by any major college that you
could think of 600 plus more
we're used by if you yeah so if you have
a sports star
they're using our stuff lebron's got our
stuff at his house at his trainer's gym
at the lakers as well as the rest of the
starting line if you watch movies
and you watch any action movies the the
stars and the stuntmen are probably
using our stuff
uh marvel studios filming right now
they're all they've got our stuff out
back in the trailer that they're
training and then
black adam same thing the rock's got our
bars
in every location that he trains at so
he's got eight of them
in all these different locations because
this is what our products do what they
do
is allow us to get our joints in the
right position and they accommodate for
variability in lifter
or human they accommodate for
variability
in lever links mobility restrictions and
training needs like
based on you know your ankle you're
going to move a little different than
other people
fairly wrong yeah he's 6'5 he's not
going to be able to do the things that
that's the reason he uses our stuff he
cannot do a squat with any
without pain with any other things than
our bars so if you watch any of his ads
videos anything where he's doing squats
lunges anything like that
that's our bar in his back cool because
it actually accommodates and it moves it
allows us to manipulate
the spinal position which is crazy it's
the only bar in the world that we can
actually
that you can actually do that with so so
our bars that do that they
they allow for the rapidly accommodating
for those needs
as well as as they're doing that
we're getting the joints in what we call
the right centration
so that's a fancy term it just means
that we have the right
proper length tension relationship of
the muscles around the joint
so that the stabilizers are working as
stabilizers
and the prime movers are working as
prime movers because when that breakdown
starts happening that's when
you start getting in that's like
breakdown and breathing patterns and all
the other stuff
right and um so
it's you know if you're if your arm's
fully stretched it's not as
strong as when it's in its optimal
working range versus when it's all the
way in again it's it's it's weaker again
so those extents so when you're arched
way up
or in these weird funky positions we've
actually got
muscles in a short position with muscles
in the long position
and so we allow that proper sensation
and then the stacking of joints and all
of a sudden you can
you can have somebody that couldn't even
do like let's say a bench press
without pain this is we could get time
for a short little story
uh yeah yeah yeah so well maybe not
funny
so it's finally in the fact that so
every major league baseball
uh coach nearly every let's say 80
probably
60 80 uh head strength coach has
shoulder problems
and they can't bench press because
they've had a surgery or pain
or whatever so it's just you know that
shoulder demands in that sport are
pretty heavy and it's just
just the way it is so i went to spring
training with one of our bars that's a
pressing bar
because they're all in arizona they're
all right by each other so i can see
about three or four teams a day
we're friends with all of them provide
you know and i go in with this bar and
they're like ah no
no i can't you know i you know i haven't
been able to bench press for like five
years it's i can't even take a bar to my
chest it hurts my god try this
take it down and it's our bar's curve is
actually
three inches greater range of motion
than others but it's built to
be able to just have these things happen
and so i did this
over the course of two days and i
visited five different teams and this
happened on five occasions
um with five different coaches same
story same thing happened
and uh they ended up working up
to two plates so 225 pounds
and doing reps with them for their first
time pressing
in years and their staff i mean because
they all know that they're standing
there just jaws hanging
down they're like gets up how about that
hurt
it didn't hurt at all no pain
just from these minor because you think
about the attraction control analogy
there's a reason i went through that
whole thing like
so much is neurological and if we're not
if we're stuffing everybody
you know round pegs through square holes
and trying to make it happen like it
doesn't work but if we
if we can work on getting these things
in the right position
the right thing is happening the
neurological changes happen
and then all of a sudden we're allowed
to move and now we can move
and now we can adapt and now we can
build resilience and now we can get out
of this
and that's the that's the beautiful
thing
is to be able to provide people the
opportunity
to get out of pain and live a better
quality of life through
developing strength it's not about
being like me and squatting a thousand
pounds like that's
not what it's about it's about this it's
about
giving that person that's been in
debilitating back pain
you know at least on life again and
allow them to get in the gym and train
and do so
pain-free that changes
people's lives it changes people's minds
yeah
it does it does some amazing things so
this is
this is why i'm so passionate about this
stuff well it's probably my backstory
you can understand the resilience piece
but this is uh
this is this is how i express it in the
world
that's very cool okay well thank you
very much for telling me a bit about
yourself and coming on
uh can you tell anybody interested in
following you where to find you where to
find your products
a little bit about your book yeah
so i've actually got a just setting it
up right now but if you go to my website
uh my personal website chris duffin
that's like muffin but with a d
it's very easy to remember um
i i will give you a free copy the first
half of my book so the book is the eagle
and the dragon
nice and uh and and so
that'll you know sign up for the email
list there and you'll get
you'll uh you'll get exclusive
educational content from each of my
companies
exclusive discounts to them uh and then
like i said a free copy of my book 100
free no strings attached other than your
email and
there's also a link uh it's it's free
but not quite free
uh i can't help that it's through
audible but you can if you don't have an
audible account
uh you can uh get my book and one up
their book for free if you sign up for
an account through my website which is a
cool deal which is why i put it on there
but you know there's you have to send
them for account so
if you've got an account obviously it's
just a credit um
same thing with social media so there's
links to all my companies there so
kabuki strength
barefoot athletics and build fast
formula um
i don't want it over you don't have to
remember screen name available just
type in nothing on social media it's
like super easy you everybody's got
these fancy handheld devices
type me in google i pop-up but the
places i interact on
the most are instagram facebook and
linkedin
and so those are those are great places
to find me
on instagram i'm doing a whole series on
change management
it's actually kind of a feeder into my
next book
so right now i think i have 13 chapters
on there about 20 30 minutes a piece
incredible stuff the most in depth
series that i've done
so we didn't talk about this sort of
stuff but uh
leadership uh uh execution
these sorts of things like i have
significant processes and depth of
knowledge there that i'm uh
working on getting out there with my
next book which is create [ __ ]
do [ __ ] live beyond the extremes
uh the unconventional executive's guide
to business and life
so uh but those three things like i
think embody a lot of what i
what i say and preach so that's for free
so go to the guides on my instagram
and you'll find them all organized right
on there
so there's great content on there
they're posted in the other areas but i
can't
they there's no way to like organize it
so the instagram is great for that so
well thank you very much for coming on
that was that was very interesting
thank you i appreciate being on
[Music]
you